arles qui célèbre le 25e anniversaire
des rencontres photographiques propose
cette année une quarantaine expositions
des soirées thématiques des stages et
notamment un stage sur le nu activités
rafraîchissante en cette période de
grosses chaleurs
reportage en jacques dufour et bruno
girodon pour moi ce qu'il manque c'est
un peu d'émotion elle dégage rien donc
on a juste une fille qui tient la propre
compte
il faut chercher autour de jeff du nas
photographe américain spécialiste du nu
chic ou 6 stagiaires ils sont venus d'un
peu partout pour profiter des conseils
du maître pour se perfectionner ou pour
changer de sujet charmant donc je
connais beaucoup de photos de chaussures
et là je viens ici pour voter contrastée
pour les nettoyer un peu l'oeil parce
que j'en ai un peu marre de faire tout
ce que je fais toute la journée et pour
se nettoyer l'oeil arles c'est l'endroit
idéal stage colloques expositions de
quoi être portée aux nues
ceux là sont d'andré kertész on voit les
photos que dans le cadre de leur époque
c'est d'avoir fait ces photos distorsion
des années 30 était quand même un
événement extraordinaire qu'aujourd'hui
c'est quelqu'un essaye de père pas tout
on va dire oui et alors voilà tu vu ici
vous allez 30 c'était quelque chose de
trop minable superbe ces corps distordue
et file et contractés superbe mais pas
du goût de tout le monde ça c'est un
monsieur qui après une 5e de verre il a
mis devant son objectif il a fait
n'importe quoi alors ça c'est pas du nu
c'est quoi lui le nul mais le nul chez
vous au moins nul mais vous et moi nue
ça peut aussi ressembler à ces photos de
cuisine sur la vieillesse ou à celle de
sorano sur la mort des poteaux qui font
peur même à lucien clergue directeur des
rencontres et spécialistes d'un eu plus
académique
[Musique]
j'avoue que ça me fait peur je le dis
franchement ça me fait peur si je
n'avais pas eu un comité artistique
derrière voix qui le propose qui insiste
jeu
n'aurait probablement pas fait des
expositions jeux là vous mesdames dix
ans je suis comme dans soleil que les
gens puissent me juger en attendant le
slash continuent à l'aider pour y avoir
mal au dos des trucs comme ça oui
non mais ça va je fuyais cette taxe nax
mêmes relaxe en tout cas beaucoup plus
que certains stagiaires un peu ému
devant cette humidité certes
rafraîchissante
mais quand même troublant c'est une
chance voilà